e
right good morning everybody and uh I'm
going to call to order the
uh inim study sub committee on SB
495 and thank you everybody for coming
uh before we kick things off though um I
would ask representative McKay as our
senior member if you could maybe lead us
pledge I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic stand one nation under God
thank you representative McKay so um
so one older them
well well but you you're you're
certainly top dog here so um so anyways
what I want to do is I kind of want to
get right into this um the we had the
uh hearings earlier in the spring with
respect to S sp495 which was looking to
bring in some certification um on uh
addiction treatment
facilities there was some concern in the
committee as a whole as to uh the
breadth you know of of the the scope of
it U maybe is it so broad that it's
going to maybe deter some people from
coming into uh uh the treatment sphere
and and is it what exactly are the needs
that we're trying to fulfill so we can
make sure that um we're actually
covering those things and the committee
was not comfortable I don't think with
going forward with the legislation as it
was there were still some gaps in
understanding there but definitely uh we
we took away the impression uh from from
the the testimony that the need was
there and it was legitimate and it would
need to have some legitimate followup so
um so here and I'm going to be chairing
the committee and uh just to quickly go
over our roles representative shipiro
has graciously offered to to step in and
to to help out as our clerk um I really
don't have any experience in in in the
treatment sphere I make light bulbs
that's my job um and that's it so but
we're very fortunate to have some folks
on the committee um who do have uh
counseling experience and representative
we also has a significant amount of
legislative experience as does
representative McKay so I think you know
between everybody that we have at the
table and with the input that you guys
are going to offer us hopefully we can
kind of you know better understand what
the need is make sure that everything is
matching up and uh we're going to go
forward with something really good my
goal at the end of today is just to have
an understanding of what the why is and
what our scope is going to be and what
information we're going to need to
gather over the summer um unfortunately
our committee researcher is not here
she's out today um but I will take the
notes from today I'll I'll followup
meeting with her so that she can kind of
get going and Gathering stuff um so that
we're not kind of caught flat footed in
September when we all come back okay so
um with that being said I think what I
want to do is get right into it in terms
of helping us to define the scope so I'd
like to start uh uh
Mr Barry if you if You' like to come
forward and just quickly give us a quick
refresher um on what the why is so we
talked a little bit in the initial uh
public hearing about you know the
podcast at 13 steps but you know more
more broadly speaking what are we
talking about what what is the need and
yeah and I was just going to ask if if
as you're walking us through this you
will
get my eye yeah and I'll just clarify
that because the three versions that we
have we have um the the version that
came over from us from the Senate um
then we have your marked up version uh
Mr Barry and then uh representative King
uh gave us uh some recommendations from
uh an organization that he works which
is the Addiction
Counseling I forget the name of the
organization addiction recovery
Coalition oh the yes that's right the
addiction recovery Coalition so they had
and it was very slight differences so
those are kind of the the three versions
that we have up here so representative
we's points well
made okay uh good morning I think I know
most of you I'm Jake Barry from new
Futures we're a health policy
organization that has been working for
more than 25 years in the substance
misuse space so thank you for your time
and attention to this important matter
um I I I do want to uh introduce my
colleagues over here U Jamie powers and
nette Escalante from uh from Gate House
treatment from Elliott Health Systems uh
respectively and then uh Sarah Cleveland
from the Department who have all played
a key role in developing this uh this
legislation um as you mentioned
representative there were uh New
Hampshire Public Radio released a 13
step podcast a little bit more than a
year ago now it uh detailed a pattern
and culture of um sexual assault and
harassment within one of our larger
treatment networks in the State uh as
part of that reporting uh it not only
went over that particular treatment
network but it exposed what many of us
had known for a long time to be a lack
of oversight of other parts of the
treatment Network as well or the Tre or
the treatment system broadly uh
specifically over
the over the summer and and the the fall
last year uh we really pinpointed uh a
specific res sorry Outpatient Treatment
where there is absolutely no uh no real
oversight mechanism by the state uh
residential treatment facilities like
many of the uh uh the ones highlighted
in the podcast are licensed by the
department but when it comes to
outpatient treatment uh there there
again this state in many cases has no
record of uh the treatment providers has
no idea who they are where they operate
and specifically cannot track uh the
quality of services that they provide uh
I I I think if you were to talk to Miss
Powers and Miss Escalante you would they
would tell you that this has been well
known for a long time that there has
been um reports uh frequently of or or
reports occasionally of people coming
from treatment that was not following
best practice that was not um you know
following proper uh uh provider patient
ratios that in some cases folks were not
uh who were employed who were uh
providing levels of treatment or support
who had not been in uh far enough along
in their own recovery to be able to
properly treat others uh you know there
there's a whole variety of sort of uh
best practices and standards that are
are um expected across the field but are
not uh we're not able to be tracked or
enforced by the state uh so that's what
we came together to really try to
address uh uh you know and that's what
this bill does it it is intended really
uh to focus only on in its current form
only on Outpatient Treatment uh it does
not does not cover residential it does
not cover 12ep programs which are not
considered clinical really is just
clinical Outpatient Treatment uh as far
as the version of that's something that
representative Weber thank you so much
for your support back in the the
committee process we did come up with an
amendment that I think uh better defined
the scope of what we were trying to do
that's been the version that I've been
going off of I haven't seen
Representatives amend representative
King's Amendment so I don't know what
suggestions they are suggesting we're
certainly happy to to look at them um
but you know really we want to Def
better Define the scope of this as as uh
outpatient clinical treatment only uh
not affecting AA not affecting other
12-step programs like that and again the
the idea is just to give uh the state uh
you know to help the state better map
out who is providing Services uh you
know across our state uh and give them a
sort of mechanism to enfor to ensure
that best practices are being followed
and that uh the the uh patients in need
across our state are are being uh
protected and served in the way that um
the way they need and I would certainly
if you're open to it I would love to
have invite my colleagues to answer any
questions
but yeah representative
Shapiro so
um number one question is um what is the
scope about patient services I mean I
assume that I assume that um is
one-on-one
counseling maybe intensive day treatment
I don't know if you can elaborate on the
scope scope and um and my second
question because maybe you want to
incorporate your answer to both of them
is there was some discussion when at the
hearing of this bill about whether we
were talking about individual clinicians
or whether we're talking about buildings
sure and um my sense is that we're not
talking about either but we're talking
about programs yes correct so um maybe
you could
just if you have any thoughts on both
either of those and if you don't I I'll
take the second part of the question
first yeah
so as you referenced representative
Shapiro uh individual practitioners are
individually are professionally licensed
by the by oplc and that's not what we're
trying to touch on here our concern is
that there are some programs or some
organizations around the state that
where this is really this kind of um
misconduct is embedded into the culture
and that if you are simply holding an
individual practitioner responsible that
that person may be removed they may lose
their license but they will be replaced
by somebody else who is going to be
pushed into following the same kind of
um questionable practice and leaving
patients exposed to the same kind of
potential wrongdoing um so this int so
the intention of this is to you know
it's not I don't want to say buildings
because this is not just looking at the
physical structure itself but it is
looking as you say at programs to ensure
that both you know certainly that uh the
physical structures following safety you
know proper Safety and Security
guidelines but also that they uh uh that
they their their practice their Pro the
programmatic elements of what they're
they doing are following best practice
and again offering patients the
protections and high level services that
that they need uh so yeah so again it is
intended not uh not to Target
individuals who are already licensed uh
not buildings per se U but programs um
as far as
the uh what as far as the the kind of
programs we're talking about here uh and
I'm sorry I'm trying to find find it in
the amendment we do try to you know we
what we did uh in the amended version
that that representative Weber was
working on we looked at uh the as Asam
definitions of outpatient services Asam
is the American Society of addiction
medicine I hope I got that right um they
are the uh you know the
credentialing um sorry the credentialing
organization throughout the country they
are the ones who set definitions who set
the the tiers of service that uh um most
service providers across the country
follow so we took the uh their
definition and we uh wrote that into the
amendment and I'm trying to find where
um I don't think
it's I don't think it's in the uh
Amendment we received but the the second
one it's in I I think the issue Mr chair
is that I'm sorry I think the issue is
that the amendment that I drafted was
never adopted because we went to interm
study so that amendment is not in the
system and what I was going to ask is
after this if Mr Barry would let me take
his copy and run down the hall with it
and get copies for all of us that might
be helpful because you don't have that
in front of you I do believe you have it
um so there's a a bunch of different
copies of the Amendments representative
Weber and he had actually sent over his
Amendment and I'd had Karen make a copy
so we have the the the amendment as by
amended by the Senate which we received
in but then there's the also the the
non-double spaced copy um of the
amendment which you have here should uh
have some highlighted okay I've got
something that's highlighted NOP that's
uh it's got the same so it looks the
same from the front but instead of being
uh right but if it was my Amendment it
would say it would not have an s on it
because okay these are the Senate
amendments here and I've got two copies
of the Senate
Amendment uh but I don't think I have
anything that would say representative
Weber in the corner which is an
amendment that I had drafted that
wouldn't be that hadn't been but but Mr
Barry did send over a
copy um oh I see so so the one with the
highlighting yes which was one gave to
you is his photoc copy of it's on the
third page yeah so if you go in the
middle okay if you go to the one that
you you emailed to me
mrry and you go we're all working off
the same great but it's right and so
what what this lists out the amended
version and and again I'm happy to to
provide copies of that helpful it says
programs and Facilities required to be
certified shall include those providing
outpatient services as set forth by the
American Society of addiction medicine
including long-term remission monitoring
Outpatient Therapy medically managed
outpatient intensive outpatient
high-intensity outpatient partially
partial hospitalization and medically
managed intensive outpatient and again
those are the categories of outpatient
as defined by by Asam the the national
credentialing
agency and you had a question
representative Weber so I'm I'm still
trying to wrap my head around exactly
what kind of organizations that we're
talking about sure
so for example I know that we have a
robust p
support operation
in
Keen does this cover that or is that
again a horse of a different color that
so uh those peer supports are generally
housing at commun recovery Community
organizations or recovery centers that
this is that is not covered here that is
not that is not clinical treatment that
is and so that is not so if I may as a
followup is is that so it's not clinical
treatment so it doesn't need need to be
regulated or it's already regulated by
DH it's they they're already uh there
are contracts in place with each of the
individual recovery Community
organizations so that that already
exists elsewhere okay great thank you
that helps me great deal representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman 65 years ago when I came to New
Hampshire I came as director of
alcoholism and in those days we had
outpatient clinics and a
hospital and uh it's been fascinating to
me after all of those years and being in
private practice to
recognize 65 years later that there's
just as much
confusion and uh lack of clarity as to
where alcoholism treatment really
belongs um
I have a nephew who's in AA and he is
absolutely totally against any other
kind of treatment and I think AA does
that routinely um the
um the the thing that has concerned me
over the years is that it's never been
clear as to what
exactly what organization our structure
it belongs to I've always thought it was
a mental health problem and that people
who become seriously addicted to do so
because of a mental health problem uh
many people would think I was crazy to
say a thing like that that alcoholism is
an addiction and anybody can become
addicted so what we're taking on is a
very very
longstanding problem in this state as to
how to Define alcoholism
addiction and does it belong under
forensic care because a lot of the
people with addictions end up in the
prison system and the County
correctional
systems uh so that uh this is an
extremely broad subject uh
and so I think the intent of this
legislation is to put it under Health
and Human
Services and then somehow under
Behavioral Health which is according to
me as mental health uh
systems and that would be a step in the
direction of saying that that's where it
belongs and and we shouldn't have this
huge
variety there is massive misuse of
facilities where people are um allowed
to go um the sober houses all of those
kinds of things uh some of those are
Highly
Questionable uh
and and that seem to be more oriented to
getting money than they are to
providing uh care
care and and providing what kind of care
and
that that is a basic question for us as
to what care
means uh does it mean get them away from
alcohol drugs or does it mean to get to
the
underlying problem that creates the
condition in the first place and this
does this belong in public health or
mental health uh
systems uh so that this is uh certainly
extremely
important um uh subject uh that's been
around for a very long time uh and there
are many people who are
suffering
significantly and not getting
appropriate care I tend to be on the
side of thinking that this is a forensic
mental health problem um that that is
not necessarily A a popular point of
view um but that with the new forensic
unit that's being developed at New
Hampshire hospital the question would be
is is that an appropriate facility to
take into
consideration uh but uh I've told you
something about
the the age Factor as well if it's 65
years ago I I came here 65 years ago to
stay a year something happened well
thank you for your service
sir um representative
Weber and I think that representative um
McKay's Point highlights the problems
that we had and are having with this
bill um his
approach is a global
one as
to the compreh the philosophy of the
comprehensive treatment of
addiction and what we have in front of
us is a very very small piece of that
puzzle and the bill that we have in
front of us is
devoted uh with this amendment solely
and clearly to outpatient
services uh rather than anything else
and so I think Mr chairman as you have
already pointed out one of the things
one of the tasks of this
committee is to First Define the scope
of what we're going to look at um
because uh there there are broader and
narrower ways to go about this and and
the bill itself is very narrow uh
whereas
um my thought would be just my own
personal opinion would be that if we are
to undertake a broader
study of the
entire scope of how we address addiction
issues which might not be a bad thing to
do I think that requires a much larger
commission with much broader
participation than we have here uh
because this is a very limited sampling
of of as as much knowledge as I see to
the right of me um I'm well aware of my
own woeful ignorance and um I I have
some experience in the regulatory
aspects but not the clinical aspects but
I I think perhaps as a as a beginning we
ought to decide as a committee whether
we're going to look at the smaller
problem
which uh would be simpler um or the
larger
problem
yeso yes so um I am very very much in
favor um of dealing with the limited
narrow scope I'm not running again so I
won't be around to
for long enough to solve the large
problem um but regardless of whether we
going to we're going to stick to this
bill which or similar bill which um
provides oversight for just a you know a
narrow group of organizations I think it
might be helpful if we get U Miss Miss
Dyer to lay out the larger picture just
so we have it as we're doing this of all
the different kinds of substance misuse
programs and what kind of oversight they
have you know which are
you know how are residential programs
um um how do they get oversight um how
do individual clinicians through oplc I
mean I think these are some of the
things that some of us know or at least
know parts of but it would be good to
have that broad picture in front of us
even as we don't address it okay
represent
Weber I think that would be a great
start uh it certainly would be helpful
for me um and the other thing that I'm
really hearing loud and clear here is
that we have this bill on the one hand
but we also have the sober houses issue
uh which is a whole which is now no
longer at all associated with this bill
um and as such I'm not sure that this
subcommittee is the appropriate place to
study that certainly the chair of our
committee could establish an ad hoc
committee on anything he he chooses to
establish one on but I think at some
point uh what we need to do is recognize
the Sober House issue and I can remember
that being addressed some years back in
the context of building codes and the
Manchester fire department being very
distressed at the conditions under which
people were living and the question of
whether they would be able to be safely
evacuated in the cour of an
emergency um but there are obviously
other issues as well that and I have not
listened to that program but am I right
to think that the podcast was about the
sober houses or was it about no okay I'm
seeing heads going the other way so okay
I'm glad to have that clarified too if I
may the um so we could perhaps leave
that issue also for another day uh there
was another bill we worked on last year
related to uh to recovery housing that
the that the house passed by Voice vote
thank you for your support for that um
it did get uh caught up in the Senate
and that that hopefully will be coming
back that's all to say there uh there's
another sort of parallel conversation
going on about recovery housing that we
would be happy to work with you want I'm
not that we considered that separate
from this bill okay I will note when
this bill began that it did Encompass
Residential Treatment providers as well
what we discovered throughout the
process was that residential uh
facilities are licensed by the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh while that primarily focuses on the
the physical plant it does cover some of
the clinical aspects that we uh that we
look to touch on here and with um those
that statute and those rules already
existing we thought that any adjustments
needed to be made by that was again a
separate and parallel process to trying
to establish this certification uh and
so so it got narrowed in in that way uh
we didn't want to uh create the wheel so
to speak for residential treatment
providers and make the department have
to license and certify the same
facilities so we thought that would be
redundant so we so that ultimately got
uh removed from the bill the scope was
narrowed a bit really to plug the whole
um the fill the Gap that exists and what
what I would argue um I I think that
there's a this is a part of the natural
maturation of our treatment Network I
think that uh you know thanks in parts
of the work that representative McKay
has done over the last 60 years thanks
very much to the uh Affordable Care Act
which required that uh uh insurance
coverage cover substance use Services
the uh treatment network has has
exploded so to speak in the last uh over
the last 10 12 years we have many more
providers doing this work than did
before and
um many of them just we don't again we
don't know who they are right we don't
know who they are we don't know what
quality of services they're provid so I
think that stepping in filling this Gap
and providing this level of oversight is
just it's a part of the maturation
process ensuring that all of our
providers are again meeting best
practice and are um serving patients the
way that that we need them
to a thank you for that so um I have a
couple of quick questions and then we
can kind of move on but before I do I
just want to say you have other folks
that are here as well so um we have we
do have space on where you can maybe
come up if you want um and and sit down
and if at any point you want to
contribute to the conversation you could
just kind of raise your hand rather than
kind of sitting there and and and
feeling like you can't participate if
you do want to come up um and there is
something as a discussion goes forward
that you feel you you know want to
contribute just raise a hand and and
we'll be happy to to bring you into the
discussion so so with that being said on
the uh because I'm talking to the mayor
of Manchester he's saying with respect
to the sober homes it's it's still the
wild west but you're saying yes we know
that there is lure from the apartment
but there's a parallel Bill we really
got to put that aside because although
that's a good thing we we really want to
tailor this down so that's so what
you're saying is we're not ignoring the
problem um it's there but we're going to
kind of come back for a second bite at
the Apple as far as that goes yeah that
from where we're coming from that has
been a parallel uh discussion with with
other stakeholders and again was uh sort
of separate legislation last year okay
um we would we would love to engage in
that as well and we'd love to welcome
you all to do so in any way but I I I
think this is a a a equally critical
issue to address okay and my second
question just quickly so you're talking
about what is uh not covered so
obviously individual clinicians are not
covered and that's explicitly pulled out
here in uh Roman 2 um and uh also um
um so 12-step programs things of that
nature so um is that what you're talking
to in in RSA 151 135 C colon 3 is that
getting how is
that the that that reference refers to
Community Mental Health Centers many of
which provide treatment but they they
are overseen by a whole host of federal
and state regulations already so we
thought we didn't want to add to that
regulatory burden okay so and maybe uh
so what explicitly in here exempts the
12-step programs then um because they
are
Exempted according to your testimony
they are
uh and maybe the best approach is to do
what representative Shapiro said and
just you know come back with the Matrix
and just kind of work through it in
September representative Weber and and I
was going to ask and I we could ask Miss
Dyer but I wonder if we have between the
experts who are here people could who
could help us with this as well it would
be very helpful for me in addition to
the Matrix that we were talking about
which which I I very definitely need is
if somebody could give me a list of
existing programs not an exhaustive list
it doesn't have to be all of them but
just some examples in each County
perhaps of programs that would fall
under this so I can look at some
something on the ground and say aha
that's what we're talking about um and
and um so I I suspect that you folks
rather than Miss Dyer are the most
appropriate people to ask for that but
I'll
defer hi can you guys hear me okay yes
um my name is Annette escante and I'm
the director for sud services at OT
health system and
um I think part of the issue is that we
don't know who's operating in
state and we would really love to be
able to not just figure out I mean right
now I could come in and just open up a
outpatient and I don't have to build
Medicaid maybe I just don't take
Medicaid maybe I just do Cash There's No
oversight and we have not been able to
identify who the players are in the
state and this is where it's it's a
crucial issue for the folks that were
serving because they don't know whether
they're a reputable organization or not
um and so that is probably one of the
bigger issues but you know the program
list is clinical people who are
providing under programs where you would
go and you would do group therapy
individual and you and there's multiple
clinicians that are in that facility but
I this has been an ongoing issue and a
problem
and although we've needed to have more
folks in the state for sud treatment we
have no idea who's operating here that's
the problem and so it's getting these
folks certified and holding folks
accountable so that we don't have 30
people in one group and someone who has
a high school diploma who's running a
group and someone who is in another
building who's signing off on these
lists so I on the groups um and this is
and I should probably just State also
that prior to being the director at
Elliott um I also was the VP of farum
Center which is a Manchester's
residential and I was also previous just
like Jamie pow the director for the
Bureau of drug and alcohol services for
DHHS this has been an ongoing issue and
a problem and it's just getting worse
and so we just want oversight to make
sure that one the clients know who to
call if something goes wrong they don't
know who to call there's no regul
there's no legislation that if their
rights get violated they can't even hang
anything on the wall there's no phone
number and this is where it became a
huge issue or a problem and so I'm happy
to do what I can um I've been pushing
this from the beginning since I left um
DHHS and knew that my voice would count
out here I could do more um which is
what I've been doing and my disclaimer
is also that I also sit on the board of
new futures and also on the governor's
commission for Alcohol and Other Drugs
um that's part of the treatment um part
but um so that's really in a nutshell
how all of this started was the multiple
complaints from clients and I think we
can do better which is why I've been
pushing this um if I had a family member
who wanted to get treatment in New
Hampshire they could just call get
online Google anything um and that
doesn't mean that we know who they are
how they're operating so um I just
wanted to make sure that I that I did
state that so I appreciate your time
yeah thank you and and so and to just
clarify as well the goal the intention
here is to kind of map the landscape yes
and to basically inforce best practice
but in terms of you know people
requiring Medicaid this is not nothing
to do with regulations around payment or
anything like that correct I just want
no just for Clinical Services okay if I
could add very quickly represent to
answer your question represent I believe
if I'm getting my numbers right I think
the DHHS has stated that there I believe
are 73 providers in the state who take
Medicaid so they so I'm sure that they
could provide a list of folks who take
Medicaid of those I believe this
department Sor you can correct me I
think the department contracts with nine
is that well there's approximately 73
providers in the state that are
contracted with Medicaid that does
include residential providers that does
incl okay out patient it fluctuates it's
depending on if there somebody is
enrolled in Medicaid or not um it's
around 65 that is umbrella organizations
it's not individual sites that may be
owned by one
organization um and again that was from
65 is list that was pulled back in I
think January so it may have fluctuated
since then their providers coming in
their providers
closing um but
and I've lost my train of thought right
now but uh yeah the total system is 73
and the department contracts with 10
facilities um some of them provide
outpatients some of them provide
residentials some of them provide both
so we have oversight of those 10
facilities and then Medicaid has Med has
oversight of Medicaid clients within the
Medicaid system but they do not have
oversight over non-medicaid clients or
anyone who isn't contracted with
Medicaid
oh and I was just if you wanted a quick
10,000 foot view of the treatment system
within New Hampshire I could give that
now representative
McKay thank you very much for your
comments that they uh they point out a
symptom of what's the matter um and that
is that people are not clear as to what
is treatment for addiction and therefore
the
general population are saying well if
these homes are they for treatment of
course they're not uh serving that
purpose so I think it's a a what you
point out is a symptom of a very large
problem we have in the state and that is
how do we
Define uh for the general public to
understand the causes of
addiction uh and and what is proper
treatment because I think people are
being treated in quotes uh in in ways
that that have nothing to do with
overcoming the problem uh so I think
it's important that we get this position
but that it's important who fills that
position and what their background is uh
because there are many
fields that there's mental health
there's addiction there's forensic work
there's there's people all over the
place who are experts in Cor in the
treatment of addictions but they don't
agree and so that what we're taking on
is a massive responsibility to be saying
perhaps we need to be
saying these are the root causes and and
this is the approach to treatment that
people should
seek that's a very large
prescription representative we I was
going to ask if just as a followup to
the frer comments you said there was a
list and there were this 73 providers
that take Medicaid some of them are
residential is there a way of getting up
us uh a copy of the list of
providers with the residential programs
taken out just so we could look at that
as a start Absolut something that we
could just just to give us a a grounding
and I I myself would love it uh Mr
chairman either at this meeting or
perhaps another meeting if it's more
appropriate I'd love to hear the 10,000
fo version so at some point yeah when
appr Jamie Powers I am the CEO at Gate
House treatment and I I think to uh
representative McKay's point is we're
not so much trying to dictate the
philosophy to but to make sure that
whatever philosophy whether your your
philosophy is 12 step based or
medication or forensic or whatever it is
that certain basic best practices are
being
followed so that whatever philosophy you
come from you are providing treatment in
a manner that is safe and high quality
treatment representative
Shapiro yeah
um this is directed um to Mr Barry
mostly I wonder if in terms
of in Terms terms of establishing what
this um Bill does exempts I wonder if it
might make sense to have a definition of
Clinical Services and the
definitions um and if that would
um that if that would make it more clear
um about what is included and what is
excluded from these kinds of
certifications I think that's something
we can certainly look at I think we can
also have a
a a stated exemption for for 12ep peer
support program explicitly yes I think
that's something we could certainly work
out
sure so I think we have some while we
don't know exactly what we're in
covering I I think we're starting to get
a handle for what we want to Encompass
within the scope um at just a question
of going through and how is it going to
be defined in as explicit a manner as
possible so I think we have some actions
with respect to that some of the
questions um that were asked of me were
and I think we kind of touched on a
little bit is are the rules already in
place and can't we just enforce those
and I think the the argument is we can't
because we don't know where people are
so I think first we have to have so the
biggest argument for C certification is
we have to have the mapping so without
the mapping it makes it very hard to go
forth and just we have the rules in
place because there was a provision I
believe within the bill for an
edsman um and so the some might argue
okay you have you have rules um why not
just have rules and allow the edsman to
basically if people are receiving
services and they are not those are not
commensurate with the rules let the
Ombudsman kind of clean that up and so
the the reason that that would not be is
just I guess you have thoughts on that
sure so I can tell you the the second
piece of the bill related to the
Ombudsman was so as amended by the
Senate it would add a behavioral health
specialist position to the office of the
uzman within DHHS the intention of that
is to ensure that there is a line of
reporting in place that is properly
trained and equipped uh uh to handle
complaints of misconduct or wrongdoing
within the system there is currently uh
an office of the udman within DHHS that
covers all
DHHS all programs and services across
the board um I think despite that um
there exists and again I'm sure my
colleagues can speak to this more
directly than I can there exists a
culture of Silence in which people are
not reporting the wrongdoing that they
are experiencing they are seeing that
applies to the patients that applies to
the staff and we want to make sure that
there are people who are properly
trained and equipped to handle
complaints of misconduct or wrongdoing
specifically within the behavioral
health space that's that's the intention
of it um uh it is somewhat separate from
the certification requirement but but we
you know we're under no illusions that
even should certification be in place
there's still is the risk of wrongdoing
or misconduct and we just want to make
sure that there are uh places that
people can go to to report it when they
it and thank you for that so um could I
ask a clarification yes you may I'm just
recalling having the scene somewhere in
one of the versions I read that uh it
would be the office the
certification tell me as it as it is now
standing who does the certifying was
that in the office of the udman or the
office of udman are the people who who
are the people you comp obviously the
people you complain to and you want to
have the appropriately trained person to
deal with that but how do remind me
about the certification sure to begin
with so the the udman is simply for the
complaint side for people to fire
complaints we had um the uh
certification uh Pro program would be
I'm trying to remember if we it
explicitly St I I think the intention is
to put it in then under Bas Bureau of
drug and alcohol Services um but we did
you know the way that we crafted the
legislation it left it to the
commissioner to develop rules around
this so I suppose ultimately it would be
up to them where they would like to
located but I but I assume the intention
desk just before we go on I I did have
um the the questions from representative
King it don't have his Amendment but
pretty much it basically um dovetails in
very closely with yours except that in
Roman one where your Amendment says the
commissioner shall provide for
scientific uh the scientific care he
just changes that to uh to provide for
evidence-based care um and uh he as well
is referencing Asam so basically taking
that language verbatim but he's saying
uh he's keeping in the language but not
limited to those providing our patient
services I think that um I think we are
pretty much in agreement that we want to
say yes that's too broad a statement
yeah to say yeah but um and we had
struck that in the so we had Struck it
so I think so if we go with that he's
looking at what's it so I guess not
knowing anything what's the difference
between the scientific care and the
evidence-based care is there something
that's different about that terminology
I would leave that to other St and I
just want to note that that line that's
existing statutory language where it say
scientific we didn't didn't touch that
in any way um but I would leave others
to to parse out the differences there
well I I just thought i' asked a
question since representative King who
can't be here had sent that over to me
and those were only really the two
differences with respect to um their
language and the language that you put
in front of us so I think um so with
that being put aside I think I said
we're pretty much nailing in on the
scope we have some homework to do um
hopefully getting the list the 73
providers with the residential aspects
taken out um and then we'll talk to uh
the committee researcher to maybe get
the The Matrix of you know the type of
substance uh misuse and you know what is
the oversight so that's I think from the
first bit of this what we kind of want
to cover um and we talked a little bit
about how the legislation I'm going on
to the next little bit on the agenda how
legislation fulfill the needs identified
um
so and the the first question that I had
and it's a common question that's asked
is is is this the first kick at the cat
or are we building this up off of you
know certification that uh models that
are existent in other states or is this
something that you guys
just this is basically a New Hampshire
grown thing sure and certainly I would
defer to my colleagues what they they
know about what happens in other states
we did some research on each state or
most states do this differently right
some have um really do more facility
licensing uh for uh both inpatient and
outpatient some um do nothing at all um
and some have some do certification for
for both residential and outpa each each
model looks a little bit different um I
I'm trying to recall if there are other
states that have both licensing and
certification program I I I don't you
know this may um you know that may be a
difference that we have here but many
other states have some um some version
of this is my my understanding yeah so
would would there be value in gathering
or what do you guys
think in terms of looking at what other
doing I would think other states are
doing a hell of a lot more than we are
so I would think it's useful if we can
find out what are the
progressive States I still have a
question of who these 73 Medicare
providers are uh and because the people
who are providing services are are not
Medicare providers Medica Med Medicaid
um and uh that
uh the I I think it's important to get
that information because that implies
some degree of Professional Training
yeah to get qualified but the the bulk
of people who are providing services are
exactly what you're talking about and
nobody knows who they are what's the
background what's the
training and what the programs are um
and but I I think it's I would agree
that getting information
from the Medicaid providers is very
important because hopefully they're
going to say these are the approaches
that one should take and not that you
need to get a breakfast every morning or
you need to sleep all night or things
like that which have nothing to do with
the treatment um so I I think getting
information from these medic providers
is essential okay Mr bar if I could just
add very briefly I think that it's
important to keep in mind as you're
looking through the list of 73 Medicaid
providers that though we we have a list
that we know who they are that we still
do not have an oversite mechanism to
enforce best practice there to ensure
that they're providing high quality you
know high quality service uh that you
know I mentioned it earlier just as a if
you are looking for a list of names of
organizations that's a very good place
to start but it's very important to keep
in mind that um should things go wrong
there there be reports wrong we still
don't have a great mechanism to step in
and and to um you know ensure the best
practices are being followed and could I
just as a clarification Mr chairman yes
please and and my understanding is Yes
again you if if it's a Medicaid Program
there will be licensed providers and you
can bring something against a licensed
provider but you can't can't deal with
the culture of the
institution and even if we have a list
of the Medicaid providers we don't have
a list of those people who are providing
some kind of service but not billing
Medicaid for it so uh so they haven't
qualified as a Medicaid provider and
don't have that level of
supervision so if I'm understanding we
don't have enough supervis Vision over
the Medicaid providers
globally and we don't have any
supervision at all over everybody
else nor do we know who exactly they are
so which is why we need the
certification program and that said I'm
more than happy to look at what happens
in other states but I think we have an
idea of the scope of the problem in our
state and I think what we ought to be
looking at um is how we deal with it in
our state because if
the states are all over the map looking
at somebody whose model initially
doesn't track what ours does um is in my
opinion not a great use of our time well
my thinking was one of the uh one of the
concerns that was raised um is if we go
down the certification route um is that
going to discourage people kind of
entering into the arena and so my
thought was is there something to be
gleaned from the experience of others
when they've gone forward down this path
H have they seen a drop off in in
certain areas um and and it may not it
may not apply directly to our situation
but you know representative who I just
don't know what I don't know right and
so um but I do what I do know is that
that was a concern that members of the
community whole hammered on and I think
at the end of the day what I want to do
is I want to be able to come back with
enough information um I I think there
are a lot of people here that want to
see this succeed but there are a lot of
people that are very skeptical as well
and to the extent that I can calm those
fears um I'd rather have well it maybe
I'll talk with with M Dyer and see what
she thinks well I I have your point is
very well taken and if we can answer
people's fears I think that that's a
great thing the other message that I'm
getting loud and clear is that
discouraging some of the people we're
talking about from coming here and
entering into these kinds of services is
a very good thing and I take and and uh
discouraging people is perhaps um one of
our goals the you know like like the
Serenity Prayer the hard part is the
Shapiro um I'd like to suggest maybe a
compromise in terms of looking at what
other states do and and instead of like
finding a whole range of um oversight
programs within their Departments of um
divisions of Health and Human Services
and how they um organize that and what
they actually um
have oversight of in those programs that
maybe we get a suggestion from um
somebody in DHHS of one state um that
they feel um generally does a good job
of um providing oversight for um Health
and Human Services programs and we look
at what that one state does and and then
we could look at some of the questions
that representative mlan has talked
about in ter terms of whether there was
a downturn in people um creating
programs um what elements of programs
that people actually like look into to
have oversight um but that instead of
like looking at what everyone in the
United States does that we pick one um
to maybe um think about how we want
model our program and and if I may the
other thing to do perhaps is to
go a little more thoroughly into our
most close sister States um because we
are competing always with Maine Vermont
New Hampshire for practitioners so
knowing what the climate is immediately
around us I think is is very useful and
hopefully some of those will provide a
model uh
for um either dispelling fears or or
taking us in a different direction one
other yeah so I can take that action
then to you know have that discussion
with the hhsc if you know hey we we
think these folks do a good job based on
our understanding and then I can meet up
with Christine and we'll just kind of go
through and look at them and look at the
adjacent States um okay representative
McKay along those same lines uh
could you and I'm talking to Mr Barry uh
find somebody who is competent to give
us a a b practicum on professional scope
of
practice because it seems to me that's
basic for what we need to know and there
are
massive points of view uh so that uh I
don't know if that's one of the social
work groups of the psychologist or
psychiatrist uh whoever it might be or
whether there's somebody that has
specialized in this that would be
massively helpful you're referring
representative to different levels of
care and and yes what what uh people are
are going seeking treatment and not
getting it and being taken advantage of
I would I I would think that any of my
colleagues here on the right might be
able to speak to speak to this to to
some degree maybe
not yeah that that would be very helpful
us oh go ahead oh I I was just gonna say
that um what we can do is if you don't
mind we can just spell it out and that
way you have it in front of you I think
would be a little bit more clear because
there maybe some of the folks who are
not here that may also want to know does
that make
sense that okay if we did that yeah is
that what you were going to say there we
it yes as as as much as I hate to
disagree with my colleague here um
representative McKay I would warn us
against um going beyond the scope of
basic best practices and delving into um
different clinical
um theoretical models I think that's Way
Beyond um the scope of this bill Way
Beyond the scope of what the legislature
should be doing and and just in terms of
my minuscule time in clinical practice
um you know I've seen a lot of um models
of
treatment come become very popular be
discredited or people just move on to
something else you know you know we
start with Freudian Drive Theory and we
like you
know it's not it's not our it's not our
job to decide which is the the
appropriate clinical models um but to
assure kind of basic
um basic safety basic best practices
basic
um respect for clients um in providing
treatment ments so I think we should um
be careful about going beyond that for
for that very reason representative the
the legislation the way we drafted it
was was was silent as regards to what
the specific certif certification
requirements are we thought that um you
know the department through an you know
extensive stakeholder process is in a
much better position to determine what
those requirements look like we're
really here to help get that process
started and and and I would just say
that you know
like my colleague here I I probably have
very strong feelings about what what
creates change and what doesn't create
change and um but you know I'm not
really sure what I believe is totally
correct
either Mr chairman just just to answer
that uh this is a sneaky way to get Joe
to come back to testify at uh at some
more legislative session he's not going
to run again
which which he knows I'm not happy about
but but that's
irrelevant what I'm looking for is a
general statement uh that the
legislature can utilize um and maybe I
shouldn't have said social workers
psychologist and so on but to to maybe
to ask the department um what their uh
definition is so that we have something
to um go on as to uh what what is
motivating behind this is a misuse of
people's disability and being taken
advantage of and that they're asking us
to stop that from happening and we have
have to have some basis for saying what
what what's appropriate practice um and
if if however we can get at that uh
repres respect
yeah our committee has
traditionally worked very hard and I
would be very unhappy to depart from
this at leaving what is the scope of
best practice to the practitioners of
that practice and keeping we the
legislators no matter how knowled ible
about that particular practice out of it
so I I want to be very sure that
we're sticking very clearly in this
subcommittee solely to the text of this
bill because we have
no and and anybody can talk to anybody
else about the more Global issues but
that's not our task here um and and I I
just want to make it very clear I'm very
concerned if we get into scope of
practice issues rather than a list of
the types of practitioners or how
they're regulated that that is fair game
but leaving to those in the field
and I know nothing about mental health
practice but I have been a teacher and
one of the things I can say is that
every child I ever met learn differently
from every other child I ever met and so
offering a wide range of
opportunities is a very good thing
because what works for somebody you know
I can take Tylenol but it isn't going to
alleviate pain I can promise you uh but
it works like a treat for some of people
um we need what we need to have is a
basic level of understanding
accountability and then we may need more
yet so I I think that's we're in pretty
much broad agreement that we what we we
want to get down to at the end of the
day is Clarity in terms of what types of
practice are being covered and what is
not so if if 12 step is not covered then
we want it to be as explicit as possible
and that's where we want to go and I
think if we can do that to start that
will address a lot of the concerns uh
that we have so I think um with that we
we hit on the bulk of the the stuff you
know I wanted to get to in the agenda
today I have a list of of action items
uh to go through to do some data
gathering over the course of the summer
so um at this point I just kind of want
to open it up is there you know anything
that um any body anywhere uh thinks that
we've missed um that that should be
brought up and should be given some
attention over the summer again so when
we come in in September we're ready to
go at it hard any additional thoughts
comments
items all right folks on the committee
we're all set all right well in that
case um I'm going to close the hearing
on uh
sp495 and I'm going to thank everybody
very much uh for coming I look forward
to maybe communicating with some of you
over the summer and getting back to work
in September all right thank you all for
your attention to this important matter